all of economics is based on this notion
of scarcity of resources what does
scarcity mean well in an everyday
context it means that there's not as
much of something say a resource as
people may need or there's not an
unlimited amount of something so not
unlimited
amount
of a resource or resources
resource and i'll put a little resource
or
is and the common examples especially in
an academic economics class when people
are talking about scarcity and the
resources they're talking about they'll
often say
land and when by saying land they're
speaking generally of natural resources
and so
examples of this would be things like
energy
it could even be things like water
it could be lumber
it could be
minerals maybe some type of metal
obviously it could be land itself and
you could see some of that depicted in a
picture like this clearly there is land
here and you could even argue maybe even
the solar energy that it has access to
that these would all be broadly put into
this category
now another type of natural resource
that is often talked about in an
economics class will be labor
and labor we associate with people
working and that is what labor is making
reference to it's all about work
effort
and when we talk about work effort we
could talk about the workers
and how much they are working so hours
of labor
hours of
labor and this picture right over here
is a clear picture of some workers
now another resource that you will often
talk about in the context of scarcity is
capital
and capital can be a little bit
confusing at first well it's things that
people make in order to make other
things
so things
made
to make
other
things
and so just to hit the point home here
pause this video in these pictures what
capital do you actually see
well there's actually a bunch of capital
in these pictures there's some of the
obvious things like these tools this
would be a clear example of capital even
these buildings these buildings are used
to maybe store animals or crops so these
are things that someone made in order to
help make other things and some of maybe
the less obvious things even you might
not even notice it at first but there's
these power lines here this is someone
made this in order to help us distribute
energy which could be used to make other
things so that too could be used that
could be an example of capital here
now the fourth resource that you will
hear folks talk about is really thinking
about well how do we know how to combine
these first three types of resources and
we could call that
entrepreneurship
some times people will refer to
technology but this is all how to
combine
how to combine
all of the above right over here one
through three these types of resources
right over here
someone had to decide that hey this
these were good places to put these
storage houses someone had to decide
where to put the power lines someone
just had to decide how what crops to
plant here and how to plant them someone
had to decide well what type of labor do
we need what type of land what type of
capital the actual factory building the
factory equipment do we need in order to
produce whatever these these folks are
producing right over here and that
general notion you could talk about as
entrepreneurship and so the big picture
here is think about the world around you
there is not an unlimited amount of land
especially if you're thinking about land
for a specific purpose there's not an
unlimited amount of natural resources
energy lumber some type of metal there's
not an unlimited amount of labor there's
only so many people who who are who
exist and there's not an unlimited
amount of capital we don't have an
infinite number of buildings or
equipment and we don't have an infinite
amount of entrepreneurship we can only
have so much energy to think about how
do we put these other things together
so i will leave you there and as we go
further in our quest in economics we're
going to see the scarcity of these four
resources show up over and over again